To answer this we're going to use this trick,
and that means we need to get p(x).
Let's call the highly actives in our sample x to simplify our notation.
So, we need that less than 2 and that is going to be
equal to p(x = 0) + p(x = 1).
Each of these is a binomial variable.
Recall what we need to figure out is the probability of the result being true--
the probability of getting a highly-active user--p(x) = 1000/100,000, which is 0.01.
The probability of x = 0--since this can only be arranged one way
we don't even need to know about binomials--is 0.99¹⁰.
The probability of x equaling 1 is going to be 10!/9!1!.  0.99⁹  0.01¹.
So, if we total this all together, we get [0.099573],
and then we'll recall from this formula over here we wanted the opposite thing,
so we just take 1 minus, this equals our answer.